I've had people say that I'm a fence
sitter and that I need to have some sort
of call to action and I guess like if
there's anything that I would respond to
that with
um given the opportunity we have now
it's like I think we need to take a step
back and re-envision
what we want the next 20 or 30 years to
look like and there's an important verse
that painted the mind a Pharisee asked
Jesus teacher which is the greatest
commandment in the law and Jesus replied
love the Lord your God with all your
heart with all your soul and with all
your mind this is the first and greatest
commandment and the second is love your
neighbor as yourself like as simple as
that is if we could just find a way to
make those two Commandments even outside
of religious boundaries if we could
learn to make that our priority and then
base our differences below that you know
like God is here our love for each other
here and then below that is try to find
a way to integrate our differences in a
way that everyone can can live a better
life